you don't mention that name in the draw
live welcome to the i Lord podcast and
Lords of gaming dotnet episode number
103 and it's another glorious Sunday
we're back at the roundtable on the
moment and we've got the winner of our
second row giveaway Division two
impressions it's Google the real next
generation threat Xbox Live on iOS and
Android project x cloud demo and steam
vs epic to discuss so we gonna get right
into it so let's introduce the four
horsemen of gaming those original Lords
of the realm here at the round table my
calls with the Kalos my brother from
another mother the difficult game
Conqueror and the how of the young wolf
mommy
doing pretty good here in this combat
talk so uh once that starts I might go
Papa Pato or something this is the day
that you won't sit down listen to grown
man MyPlate my xbox is even hooked up
right now so I can't even escape relax
and your PC's otherwise occupies you
know I've got two screens monitor how
you said she always has the out just the
division pretty much did the guard
division that the anthem killer division
but I wouldn't say Destiny's killer I
would say the death City killer division
at this uh this last expansion they
dropped actually wasn't it's not bad so
say the Destiny killer divisions but
I'll definitely say an anthem killer
division this is a good time to talk
this is what it is it what to be fair
you have to have life to be killed kill
something that's already dead I mean
can't kill something to killed itself
Wow that's what that game obviously you
know your history at that was quite
interesting on social media oh so is
this like your Redemption show is this
that I told you so - what is this as
mine
we want to play a game telling you is
better than your game anything goes
what's our division sir no not really
just playing the division I've been
playing a lot of destiny PC and add some
Devil May Cry 5 and of course we have
our most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single-player
selfish experience and also the sastra
darkness mr. offline profile Illuminati
and lore patron of the iron bank my man
Lord sovereign I do sir I'm chilling man
doing good
Oh your bikes good man vitamin D I will
edit that one oh man I did the scheisse
this week and I took my PC to to work
with me I had that in my backpack
finally I finally got through a finished
crackdown that was it was fun man I got
you know the boy I don't know people
talk about the boss fights him or not I
mean I honestly it was a very solid fun
game I love the traversal and so I
pretty much did there's still a lot of
achievements and stuff what crazy stuff
by gathering all the ores which will
never do so I finished that um I play
some division man like honestly yeah I'm
liking it I'm really liking it I don't
go into the weeds with it like you guys
do you know with all the the upgrading
and stuff like that but I did you know
for me
Justin finding new stuff and see the
numbers higher
okay cool I like that like that for me
that's enough let me ask you because you
because you you the King a single-player
experience so my thing is I felt that I
could play that solo like how what how
is your trick it's clearly you didn't
play with that so loves you because well
jokes aside like how is that for you say
it's definitely not it's very playable
single-player the only thing I really
had trouble with was control points
control you are an absolute beast
see the thing with the control point was
that when I first did it and I cleared
out the initial wave I thought it was
over
why they telling me to call back up I'm
like alright I didn't get anything
something like all right let me do this
backup thing maybe it's gonna send NPC
is my way to help me or whatever and
then when the rust came on oh that's hot
yeah they were ruthless they were they
murdered me quit fast like so you need
help for that yeah what you gotta do
solve is on before you if we trait the
control point we're gonna notice like if
you crouch behind something you'll see
press X to call back up and shoot the
flare up run out let me give you the
advice when you shoot the flare up its
takes some time let's just a settlement
in the general vicinity take some time
for them to get over their nose n sorry
I would say soon as you start the
engagement then shoot it up so that at
least in the mix by the time is mixing
up then they come cuz you when they come
I trust ya oh my god do these guys and
never I love the fact that they're so
relentless with their aggro and they're
flanking they don't care about you they
don't care about your cover they're not
actively you know what I like the
conversations that they have healing
I like the ones I like to do that I just
like they don't care they throw
themselves out there they shoot at you
with the gun sideways walking sideways
you haven't seen nothing yet to get to
the suicide bomber dealer the growing
chest and it take you see know when they
take the drugs to get you when I said on
with the girls that are in the hyenas it
is home rush you I'm like you know what
is going on why they gotta get high
before they're doing the kamikaze they
know they're not getting out of that
alive but they want to get but you know
I like that touch right because it adds
to the reason why they going so crazy so
like to rush you right because normally
wouldn't make any sense tactically to go
at someone like that exactly but they
know that they're expendable then you
know I gotta say man Wolf Man it was
funny while I was playing cuz this we
you know you know um how about when I
share it right so while I'm playing
I see the notification pop up for the
year one pass like a carboxy was lately
now I gotta get the you unpack now
that's pretty much it I wanted to touch
a little bit more of a double my car but
I've been able to do that and then this
week is mansukh hero Friday no doubt no
doubt and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the XS gamer
ooh the lord of combat sports was a man
whose convictions demands nothing less
than opinion experience and is the
leader of the fraud alert movement Oh
beloved Lord King how you do exist
commuting
let's go manhandle a room right now I
won't beat you but you need more than
that Raymond Morel playing Davitt with
the fire on a super chat playing
Division two by yourself need backup a
turret a drone in three as soon as I put
up that - funny thing is as soon as they
see the turret they all try to destroy
it like it's not they all go after that
you got to get that out of turn I'm
gonna give you a shout-out to that
because you did call a decision on that
and I'm gonna explain why that decision
went down like you saw because
technically your boy was knocked out
since the knife round when his brother
wanted to jump on a rope and throw in
the towel that happened just like I said
his brother gonna jump on a rope and
throw in the towel but this how it went
right the whole narrative we're talking
about eros prince jeongan versus mikey
garcia a lot of moves out have you
listened to her combat talk a lot of
dudes out he was running with this
rhetoric a little big man can go a
little a little a good little man can go
up and beat a good big man that has
never happened in boxing now I want you
to understand eros prince is in his
prime he's an Olympian he's going around
he's seen every style in the world as an
Olympian all right then I knew that he's
no see he has fought every style so he
had to adjust to every style right this
man is a certified animal when I'm
telling you he's an animal I believe he
is part Michael Myers and part Jason all
right because this dude's face if we
watched every round he had a particular
mission his face never changed this face
stayed the same he didn't have a heavy
breathing this man had a mission his
mission was to make Mikey Garcia never
speak his name again
he beat this loose two minutes for every
round and backed up office behind just
so he can carry him for a fight I know
when you're carrying somebody he carried
his
behind to teach him a lesson don't you
ever speak my name he beat him so bad my
point look like a crippled old man just
let him fold man made himself
it was sadistic it was it was that it
was definitely that because I stopped
yeah he doing some pantomiming joint
teasing him he said stop that stop that
right now because he was it was like a
cat playing with a mouse you see we kept
playing with a mouse before yo I've
never seen a destruction of great
fighter cuz mikey is a great fighter i
called cranial shoutout to Dave from UM
Vegas Vegas made him stay and the dm's
talking about it's not home be shy
thanks yo I called it back then I said
Errol Spence is going to slaughter this
man mm-hmm
string his body up for all to see don't
ever speak my name that is the true
boogeyman and I don't beat them I don't
know how they gonna beat them Oh Agis
gonna beat them so you gotta mean giving
me a good one you gave me a girl one
cake to get back at the box when you say
Alex Perez gonna be my wave away from me
that's your new Roy that's to do all
right yo quick real quick yo stay to
chat go across bull say your post fight
with Straight Outta Compton commentary
was fired he said yo people was like yo
de Jason my boy he's him you know said
pummeling your 108 he said he'd beat up
like Tyson beat razor ruddock the second
fighter out yo they said everyone agree
with you they said their caddy would say
oh they let him suffer me like heroin
yeah like if I'm a technical perspective
the only thing that what Mikey couldn't
do what he needed to do when we couldn't
do is that he needed to neutralize the
jab right so he needed to step in at an
angle to his left and try to smother the
jab and then maybe hit him with some
dirty boxing box for the body try to hit
him with some uppercuts
his friend
was moving too much he had no likes pens
had him on the straight line the entire
time Spence he hit him with the jab and
then he come right back with either the
straight left or a hooking left just to
throw just to throw his timing off you
know yeah no no no right so no he would
he was he was hit him with the right jab
and he and he come back well straight
left or the hooking left so that so my
thing was like Mikey at least try to hit
at angles and kind of duck into what's
his left
- maybe smother the right hand and in
the jab he might have had a chance to do
something yeah except stand up in front
of him the way Spence was moving around
him he kept him in front of him all
night Mikey was he was on the centerline
the whole night getting pummeled I never
seen anything like that control he
control for such a good boxer like Mikey
to get controlled like that that was
something to see yeah he needs he needs
to go back to his weight class and I
want you to go to combat talking I told
you it's gonna be two men and they're
fighting for control Dan Amerinet gonna
get that control I already knew screams
let me get that control all right he
doubled tripled and quadrupled the jab
on Mikey you say he was hitting with
Jazze Mike he was like what the hell is
going on is going on who is this dude
that's in front of me cuz I thought he
was just a bull a bulldozer dude I told
people to do this right this is how you
way of a fighter how the fight is going
to go you take all their fights and you
take those guys and you put it on the
other guy and if he can beat those same
opponents in the same fashion then
you're gonna have a good fight I took
all the spins opponents and put them
against Mikey in my head
I don't see Mikey beat none of them
right then I take Mikey Garcia's
opponents and I put Spence against them
mm-hmm Finch destroys them and knocks
out all well he would have a perfect
record that's when I came us yes it's
gonna be a hell of a slaughter smarter
imagine quick question so now that he's
done this like who's the next logical
thing for Spence like what's the next
challenge because it are some other dogs
talk
reckless discipline and I was also me
yeah one somebody I'm gonna be answer
that real quick won't you tell you the
truth okay
yeah real quick cuz right at this point
what's the next time cuz we all the
consensus expenses that do so but it's
pretty so quarter just really took al so
let list this look at that photo doesn't
anybody out that's 1 2 and then again
port is the it porters issue yeah I mean
he's a true and well Kuwait in that
regard but the same issue is Mikey same
issue like he's the dude that fights on
the inside he's constantly moving
forward Spencer's going to jab his head
off and just spin around him all night
so I don't see that's been good fight
but I mean Spence he's gonna get a big
money fight with Manny that's gonna
happen like Manny what that's what the
fight Manny Manny Manny look like he
wanted to fight but it seemed like was
gonna happen
he called many oh they brought this
front sides the seats for Manny right in
Floyd he paid for Floyd and Manny's
tickets five thousand dollars apiece for
those front row seats uh jerry jones uh
made sure that he you know he covered
that for them and specifically for those
two to beat it
thrashing remember floyd is his boy
that's the dude that gave floyd the
black eye and made fry stop sparring
that day that's Adrien Broner while
Adrien Broner was standing up when it
was sparring and made Jim Brown a cry
though ooh that's to do that he spars
with the charlo brothers he man oh man
listen well ok so yeah it Shawn Porter
was supposed to fight him this fight
right mmm it was supposed to be no Mikey
it was supposed to be Shawn Porter
versus him remember no sharp ordered in
with that smoke so Shawn Porter for his
mandatory oh sorry I got my man
but if boogeyman stuff is shodhan Oh
nobody want that dude Sean Porter's
gonna void I'm Shawn Porter was give up
his damn belt before he fights him
before Keith Thurman fight so they can
cash out two bums right man is looking
for if I Manny is trying to stay
relevant keep a belt so Floyd can find
them so they can get that money
I don't want Manny to fight him I don't
know doesn't that's not nice which is a
great oh man so old man will be
destroyed no I don't want to see that
that's like okay I got you what you were
playing cake would you let me talk about
another bigger vision whoa yo man monkey
I have been in Division streets yo
shout-out to you a monkey the only
people in the ILP division cleaning
solution on about I'm gonna talk about
the issues cuz everybody's not here with
the deliver division love so I'm gonna
give you some fish but um yeah I told
y'all before Anthony was in the bushes
and I didn't know how anthem would
survive the onslaught of Reznik unit to
be damned and then these guys coming
more um but everything so let's get to
the top oh right and of course it's me
Lord Cognito
the cooperative experience Lord and
everything else having so much fun man
division oh so much man it's it's been
insane man I've been doing them I
started season two drifted oh just to
get a touch of that you know I'm saying
invitation now it's actually pretty good
you don't say the stories late shot the
Sinister and all that we've been doing
that but yes but division all day shout
out the dizzy and a chat you know since
our attic whiskey pity man sinister
marks move you know I'm saying we'll
talk about the Klan stuff later hashtag
blame King this whole thing going and
you have people
lose what the clan rewards right back
like the clan is really a big you know
what I got a shout out the dizzy on that
fraud because you sitting out there
talking about you out in these streets I
can't see you out in division now one
day one day on the weekend when I don't
play when debo in the streets we got
some announcements to make
sir we do have some announcements to
make so our secure old leme giveaway has
come to an end and once again shout out
to our brothers from the north from
Winterfell once again was I like the
squirrels have invaded our land steal
our Sakura code a hold a real quick fire
on a super check yo Raymond marell thank
you brother
you said eight Lords I put down with
this division clan I'm struggling in
these DC streets by myself cake man we
got people 16 micro me on xbox uh King
David OTW same as my Twitter all right
just add me if you don't add me I don't
see how about that at him and hopefully
you get what's going on with that sort
of to the north evaded to the North
invaded yet again to steal lost a key
role cause I thought it was gonna be
mean that one but you know
conflict of interest so the winner of
our sucky row game giveaway
lord
RACI k77
Oh No rangiku thank you so much my
brother for all the support you are the
winner of our gleam Sakura giveaway so
look out for the code in your DMS well
first I'll contact you let me know what
what system you wanted for and then
we'll get that right over to you so
you're ready to go by Friday that's was
best relations and thank you to everyone
but everyone who entered so and will let
you know in your future what our next
game giveaway is going to be yes sir
shout out to Lord snow for once again
yeah being the hammer camp and making
sure that these gleam giveaways go
smoothly sudo should offer premium
because uh he has to deal with a lot of
uh sheisty make sure people try to get
they finagle also we have another
announcement - so shouts of saw saw for
that yeah hear ye hear ye
part two as you can see I'm saying we we
got that Lords of gaming in the building
on saying and um first off like um the
link like the tremendous response that
we've got from the writer's opinion
pieces the reviewers it's been truly
humbling they're so so proud of the site
and I'm saying I mean you know saying
our editors at one of them on the front
panel there and all of our Rockets who
have contributed so um with Lords of
game and Garnett you know I'm saying
it's being like a Brandis like
grassroots just kind of a new entities
kind of inspiring to see all y'all
that's really rockin on us and it's
built up from the ground up you know
saying like this is a passion of real
game is so shot everyone who support
that long net movement you know I'm
saying but this is the South caller arms
now it's except the whole arm so now
we're actively looking for those who
want to get into games meeting with a
specific purpose or like breaking news
like that's or like we're very timely
fashion or just commentary or any of the
latest news that goes on and I'm saying
so we love the talent that we currently
got y'all nice this is no this is y'all
good money now we trying to expand a
little bit more so um yeah so please
like I said when you get a chance go to
it's gaming neck I'm gonna put that in
the description that's the Twitter so at
Lourdes gaming that give me a second I
throw that bad boy in there and on you
hit that up if you look at the top of
that it's gonna be pinned there's
another here you hear you want an
application hit that up you're gonna be
saying and like I said hit my little
beat to myself and our editor-in-chief
Lord Izzy who's in the chat will be
reviewing the next round of worthy Lord
Lord so get to it you know I'm saying
and what that gamer knows in the room
that you know can truly come from the
penis I mean I'm saying this is from the
people this is a grassroots man we
started something new and we wanted real
gamers behind it so again at Lords
gaming neck it's in there hit it up you
know I'm saying if you want to talk
about breaking news and all that good so
what he's looking for and what we're
looking for we're looking for that new
DJ academics we're looking for that dude
that's on top of his game that dude that
you know the trihard dude that anything
that he has that he did he digs and he
finds out the truth to it like um the
finest the finest is always hitting me
with great need work and I'm the finest
I'm shouting I'm shouting you out right
now I really think this is up your alley
you know I bet you jumped in here right
now and you jumped in right on time so I
really honestly believe this is really
towards you
you already got a toe up in the in the
mix so young Chris young chris is like
me yeah we did our little academics you
know save for the lords break that
breaking news in a gaming culture what's
going on you know but like I said love
to everyone man it truly I mean we've
been like live for two weeks feel that
long
it doesn't feel that long at all not
even a month man and just yet to see the
people that are just see what we're
doing and really just want to take that
opportunity to jump in and do something
they probably been passionate about but
been afraid to do is amazing man like we
have just so many people to just
passionate about specific subjects
whatever and just just go out there and
do it man like again we're so happy to
have you guys come on and be willing to
write for the site it's been an amazing
turnout really has been absolutely saw
you Lord acting
that makes out there like jonathon be
said make sure you sign up your Lords of
gaming that net yeah he's funny it keeps
logging me out all you got about the new
podcast I don't know how to lead like he
definitely is cuz he's not he's now in
the ready to loop the podcast if he like
a second ago there's two of my icons pop
up like Google Hangouts is tripping
right hi bro just stay stay with you
because it's about the Buddha dadada if
it boot um is fine as long as we started
fun to get addicts or better they going
anyway so Shanna OC Louis now the
building is upset so let's get it to
this poll last week poll results are in
and the people have spoken to the
question with the recent ps4 firmware
announcement allowing remote play
functionality to iOS phones and tablets
do you think this will eventually lead
to Sony adopting a more aggressive
streaming approach with PS now the
winner at 61% of the three-way ILP poll
is yes similarly x cloud PS now will
also evolve to any device group coming
in at second place at 26% was the no
remote play has existed for years
PS now will also remain the same group
and coming in that last place at only 13
percent was that I don't care I'm not
interested in till I get PS now or by
toaster group in last week's poll Lord
King where you at with this man I told
you
you Sony dudes out here so reactionary
just like Sony they always watch what
everybody do and they followed him they
found monkey-see monkey-do stop it
really getting disgusting that one can
say something and next week the new head
to do that cuz the other dude got
assassinated he got a Saturday why Phil
is the only consistent in this in these
streets and all these heads is
disappearing and showing up with new
bodies the gig that we feels that way so
we got that going on you know they shine
at the dreadful Hennessy bro yeah we
don't get into these topics attic please
don't look the podcast you still here
sir is he okay cool so let's get into
these topics man I got PD in the
building but on we had a big launch this
week right yeah we did the division I
had to mute my mic I have stuff going on
would you prefer me to keep it on King
David hurry is I want to know what's
going on I know you don't so you know
obviously there's no no secret that the
Lord's are all of us besides Lord
solvent or you know a big fan of loot
shooters we play quite a bit of them
except for ants you know we actually had
the division to pop in on you know a lot
of us besides the Lord King I don't
think we're recording you know after a
couple weeks you stop playing the
division with me or I what division
original division yeah me a band uh
state was mad at you no there there
the what was that thing called that
supposed to be the raid in the division
a key for dota there is we had that you
know we had all that go on but now it
feels like what the division of two
actually played it shout-out to lure
kognito it's actually it's a really good
game this big coming from you cuz you
like myself
well maybe even more of a quote-unquote
division hater than and I was division
one yeah I'm on most of all I'm sure you
could go back in the older episodes and
see me multiple times saying that I
won't touch this game at all and I
played it I tried it out and it was a
running simulator so I stopped playing
and so but you know this game they fix a
lot of my issues that they had with the
franchise and it just shows another
thing that I'm honestly starting to
think you be softs the best publisher in
this generation well it's funny you say
now TK blam shout to the shop podcast
game before taser in the chat we had
that as a topic and he had Capcom and
some other and he's like is all be like
the best you know saying right now and
argument could be made of you really
look at that resume right yeah like they
they took they couldn't fix certain
things from the original division
because it was built into the actual
gameplay mechanics but they're like look
we'll fix everything else but that but
we got you with the division - and they
had us funny facts not facts okay now
that he's been out in these streets this
I want to get our PD in here man because
uh you know he is the resident division
expert shout-out to him and his dream
team he's always streaming that as well
as one of his great articles up on Lords
of gaming dotnet you can check that out
as well he does a weekly updates so P
man it's been about a week now you know
the first would mean this is the first
week like give us your experience with
the game your impressions how are you
feeling about division 2 right now so I
will tell you this I have about 24 hours
already in lodging right now and I'm
only a level 26 and I'm still pushing
content like hard and I can't
you how much I love going into seeing
like what they what they've changed what
they've improved adding to different
weapon types because you know that the
the rifle the assault rifles once a
Christian one they've they've taken
everything they've learned from Division
one and they've taken it and just stuck
it right into the vision too and then
they've improved on and like the random
pop-up quests when you're running around
I mean it's it's very impressive what
they ended up doing and changing and
listening to the people and I'm not
saying like you know there the game
isn't without bugs there there's
definitely a handful of bugs like the if
you have a chem launcher and you're
shooting to heal you can accidentally
like shoot the thing across the room
instead of dropping on the floor you
could end up seeing a lot of glitches
within the within the animations like if
you knock into something on a wall and
there's like a couple of things it'll
start glitching and then next thing you
know you see like a stuffed animal just
like bouncing across the room and
cluttering it's it's crazy but I'm
actually very impressed with what
they've ended up doing mmm that's what's
up man now again you've been championing
this game like you've been waiting so
long and then I guess it's one of those
things with like do you do you feel like
the indicated cuz I know like I said
you've been you've been even when the
anthem was strong you as I go I'm
getting it but that's efficient like you
always was you know I'm saying like true
to that like PT so like is it how's that
feeling like the D in your opinion kind
of you feel like they delivered on the
promise so to speak first first time I
gonna say I'm not like an anchorman with
76 you know I will say that I I've been
waiting for the division 2 for a long
time and they what's really interesting
is that they announced division 2 almost
a year to the day of the launch which
was really interesting and many people
didn't realize that and they've said
that the game was already 2 years in
development
which means they were only a year into
Division one and they already started
developing division two so they already
knew that the IP was going to be a big
deal and it was gonna bring a lot of
people and I I think they did a really
really good job of what they ended up
doing and taking a person like me who's
a huge fan of the first one and seeing
what they did with the second one I'm
I'm very pleased I'm very happy with
what they ended up doing and I I can't
wait to see what they're gonna I think
it's next week or the next week after
that they're gonna activate the the tier
4 sorry the worlds here for world tier 5
because they hit they haven't activated
that portion yet so everyone is pretty
much sitting at worlds here for show
frozen shop egg a male who's back on
your neck pts a fallout 76 still goes
shut up
got their video the only one in the
online community over there he said that
Ubisoft is like the new rockstar this
gen several new IPs with tons of content
rockstar is just money grabbing off
reputation so he's like we'll be out
here alright so let's get Lord soft and
King in here man it's it's release time
the first week y'all be touching
disclosure and full disclosure Ubisoft
is you know brought the King out alright
shout out the you saw too many occasions
were you being bought out talks to the
crowd
[Applause]
how did this come about I have my own
business being minded and so I opened it
up and they said you've had the whole
big thing I was like no so open it up
and it was like thank you for attending
remember when I tend to dejoy my name to
try our finest whiz the realm has been
compromised listen you can say whatever
you will say I'm telling you off the
truth I didn't have to tell you what was
going on in the backyard I just wanted
you to be clear and what I was saying
next you know so um okay
we was on net on for honest stuff and
all this stuff and the Dance Central
stuff who is looking at all that stuff
I'm in a good time that's nobody no
pizza all right
so um it was a little thing that we
signed up for the division stuff and one
of the developers was like oh do you
play I said yeah you know real heavy on
my xbox he said do you play on PC I said
no not at all he said okay what type of
Ritalin I told Rick I was wrong he said
oh you definitely should be playing on
PC I don't think so
I really don't think the best and I'm
not gonna happen I really don't think so
he said well you know try it out over
here on PC so I went over there and I
tried it I was like yo it looks really
nice but I'm not gonna do it so um I
said I know I'm already gonna buy the
DLC and all that other stuff he said
okay take down my information lo and
behold dude do you remember me send that
joint to me so that that's a nice thing
I'm going to purchase it on PC I'm this
rig is going run net I'm gonna see what
it look like it's nice I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna lie it is just mean oh you
guys are gonna play PC with me now like
one or two days with you and then it's
gonna go right to the bushes um why
check this out
all this love that you're showing I got
a bit real problem because I was a I was
basically the Jordan phrase meme on
Saturday and reason um the clan now I'll
see the clay in there right
start the IOP clan lima a monkey in my
party
click on his name I said let me see
Hamid just add them cuz I think you just
click him his name okay cool hmm I stood
there for probably a half an hour put in
monkey's name and I said why isn't that
giving me enough words like lettuce to
put this man's name
I couldn't add withstanding this is the
most BSB you know what I want I wanna
add kognito
so bad so he could be admin so he can
add horrible Oh the next thing with that
game I'm playing I'm in the middle of
the fight I said let me throw down my
turret so we can set it up why is my
turret still stuck on my hand and I
can't toss it oho and it happened on
numerous occasions that I'm running
around with a hacky sack in my damn hand
getting shot at and being murdered in
these streets had to switch to my gun
fight it off and then after a while
after I do my um the drone then I can
throw the turret on the floor glitch I
don't like I don't like the glitch where
sometimes you can't leave an instance
and everybody your whole team you go in
the elevator
all y'all just fall to the floor dude
alone a little headache you shot the
slow-mo he said he and no problem and
his nineteen age you got to give us a
destruction of itself
yes slow-mo and work walk me through
this because obviously at my advanced
age I'm stupid
shut up
shivering how hard you want at people on
destiny for not beating the clan and not
doing the clan things and you didn't
even make a clan you have to also do two
missions in the first settlement to
unlock other people can't get into clan
unless they do the same thing so that's
that's wack yes unless you got your land
bad you can't come in unless you got a
clan badge no clan badge no joining
break breakdowns anymore experience with
the division on this first week of
launch like I said I've only done a
little bit like a first the first couple
of missions I opened up like the theater
settlement did the mission where you
rescue the leaders daughter and stuff
like that um and like I said for me the
coolest part about it is what I liked
about the first one - is this the
movement the the mantling over stuff
everything is so smooth everything it's
beautiful the the tactics that you have
to utilize I think are really smartly
done the fact that the enemies are so
aggressive and they don't really care
they'll be like you um it means that
like you know an engagement with with a
with a low-level enemy can turn into
something crazy if you happen to run up
on them and then you know before you
know it cuz when I I had one engagement
where I saw these dudes in front of me
so I engage with them but it was at like
a crosswalk so there was an open street
to the left and right of me so all of a
sudden their boys came out from the
other side and I was sandwiched in
between them so now my movement has to
change completely so I'm you know I'm
trying to get the high ground I'm you
know doing all kinds of different stuff
and that's me is the most fun part about
it yeah absolutely
the ludus shooter stuff like you know I
don't go deep into into the woods with
it like you guys do but I do like the
fact that I'm constantly getting you
know a new backpack or a new pair of
gloves or something like that I like
that but no though yeah man let me jump
in man it's been it's been wow like it's
been
what a launch man I just got a I'd be
able to give up to Ubisoft man because
at the end of the day regardless of what
anybody say late they had a lot of
pressure I'm saying especially with you
know the anthem scrutiny and let's be
real like none of these Lula shooter
these launches have never really
flawless but this is probably as close
to seamless as you can get you know and
for the record like division two might
not be everyone's style of ludus shooter
in terms and everyone likes but as far
as like being polish feature-rich for
the most part - kings issues now buddy
yeah they're like I've never seen that
launch so I mean yo they delivered for
me like 4k the HDR don't be at most the
like saucing softer about the HDR
because I think they fixed it with
yesterday's patch the third day and I
couldn't change my HDR slider and it
defaulted to like 250 and you know our
our TVs could do like 1200 nits yeah
well I can't move it so yesterday after
the patch it worked fine yeah so it may
be quick with like about two or three
patches already you don't say so like
only X it is stunning like okay go for
it would you guys consider destiny
anthem and the division to loot shooters
like Borderlands I don't think you could
compare them I'm sorry I think these
games were built off the foundational
Borderlands but they're not the same
type of games I would I would say I
would say that's what he stands because
I would say that Borderlands gave off
like you said a foundation but if you
really look at that these are a little
different in the way they're structured
and I'm saying but I think the loot
aspect think out from one lens they'll
say like it was like the more these loot
shooters come out the more people like
it that it's good in Portal and like
like ain't nobody saying portal and
trash it's like a pure story yeah that's
one thing about Borderlands I never
really played well last but it's
Borderlands a living game like these
games are no it's not yeah it's more
structured linear in that respect and I
think a lot of people maybe thought
anthem would go down that right route a
little bit but no I mean shot at the
bottom
what a given I mean we give it up the
boil is all the time my topic shout out
the packs with that game and we gonna
beat it
shut up today absolutely but yeah maybe
on that one you make the client jump he
jumps in my parties just to say hi what
you doing I said I'm doing this attic
what's going on then he just leave you
no use in person he's disgusting the
stuff that he do and everybody go you
know that gift for the of 50 cent in the
back like passings looks fantastic going
shout the king pc ain't no slouch man PD
I seen it man 60 frames oh my it's it's
smooth yeah why don't we I cannot front
you know I'm saying like the gameplay is
literally a love letter to everything I
hate about Division one like everything
I do like this is the delay the vicious
should have been that girl I was sitting
with Cognito and the whole time I'm
sitting there with my fraud alert on
like this right so I'm playing my game
cogito is playing with me right and I'm
like this kognito that I have ordered a
red one at that blue we're gonna be the
fraud King don't want to call fraud on
himself I have you guys like I always
say like this is the way it should have
been like like his office a super
aggressive the enemy AI had a flank they
utilize their own skill you got the
faction behavior types of hyenas have
run down their butts off with the WoW
you know said style you got the true
sons they dropped which that was up you
know what I like about the the yellow
bars like the real boss boss yellow bows
where they blame the boss was unto the
Builder with a high high priority be
kind of me yeah but when you shoot them
any warmer
coming off and they working it all for
their body I said Wow now is like
remember when you was complaining like
this old bullet spongy my right but when
he's taking off his armor he becomes
less bullet spongy and he's allowed you
know you can never what damage is really
good is those go to a walk through light
like like the Terminator man so just
keep walking down the hallway it's like
what is it gonna take
okay so on you guys will actually
experience when you're fighting those
guys they will actually re armor up and
in full heal and then get a heal bar on
top just like you've got to be kidding
me
us here at the iron Lords prefer to kill
people before they do dumb [ __ ] like
that I've been running so low and it is
is challenging it is vastly harder even
the story mode I can't believe how hard
they made the story mode which you get
for playing that PC I do the whole
entire story I will do the first tier
one so low to the point where I and then
my buddies like in a dark room with
their to drop the gives that really
rewarding you know I'm saying what I
like is that that seamless transition
from like the outside inside no loading
all the the ragdoll physics when you
bust them don't say like the lore time
to kill it really feel like you Merkin
them like you're super south oh shut out
to all that nothing with the fallout of
super chatter love the show guys keep it
up thank you brother it means a lot
that's how we read stuffed as pops
none of a king to talk game will only
talk for the me and Erica was going at
that you know it's it's easy to say you
can't be brought out to that back that
truck starts being back down no I want
to point out that that people's already
bought Lord King David with just games
and that's like somebody on top I told
you listen first of all shout out the
l-boogie that's part of ILP okay she
thought it was super funny and making me
play anthem she heard the thing I put
out a I'm not playing a game unless
somebody purchases it and I'm Anna and
it was hilarious that I get out later
had to be a man of my words night Lord
kognito nods out of ten when I go at a
game don't I not play the game yours go
you go you go I know you shout out the
jollity beat they call it King Paola all
about the bag anyway about it we got
Kings speaking part out the way with
Paola you don't have you say anything
like it feels real when you shoot don't
get the critter shooting feels real
general it feels so much Taino destiny I
would say there on time a sound great
because they sound great shout out to
Riggs when the rig's play good gear up
y'all get them rigs yeah shout out the
breath now ran inside brat 1 brat was
like you know I need help King I jumped
in the room and I came in there with the
automatic shotgun Oh easy story with a
goat shot and killed him yeah
any game any game that allows you to
shoot grenades out of the enemy's hands
and let them kill themselves with it
like I do yo tell me now don't be scared
PD we hit they accuracy to get you out
of that spot like data all the days of
you staying stationary in one spot you
clean up that's a wrap
not only they gonna rush you they gonna
flank you they're gonna throw grenade
launchers at you they got they own tech
they own centuries their own stuff like
it's very aggressive man and I'm like
the difficulty kept Union I got two
things one have you have you experienced
the rocket launchers yet when me what a
lot of people don't realize and they've
actually did a deep dive conversation on
this in Division one when they
introduced the hunters it's more
advanced AI intelligence in comparison
to what the normal right so they ended
up doing was they took the information
that they gathered from the AI from the
hunters and they actually took it and
put it into every single one of the AI
players now you have that advanced AI
which allows them to learn about the
flanking to learn about where you're
they're going and you you have a vastly
harder experience and that's why they're
always pinching you and cutting you into
corners and doing those things which are
not you know you're not used to or
thinking and the other thing is that I
have an experience yet but I've heard
people that as low as level seven and as
and around they've actually experienced
hunters in the world while they're
running around
like they'd use like a regular do you
take about hunters are totally different
they're just regular they're they're
NPCs but they're vastly harder to kill
and if they come up on you they will
one-shot you probably the hardest mobs
you will experience and fight with and
deal with and they they're really hard
and they'll really change the experience
of what you are used to scramble
scramble your tech so but you if you
beat one and you take his mask mmm is
the mask that he drops then you get to
take that mask I don't know what it does
I got a diamond achievement for it
that's great I've never seen one I mean
that's crazy and another thing I like to
that nobody talked about is that they
kind of addict they kind of got a jerk
Eric tur with this random vendor that
comes right Petey yeah so I have another
person to disappoint me every week so
this guy really he doesn't do much for
you this random character they do he's
almost like a snitch so you find him and
you can talk to him and he'll be like
hey go see this person over here Cassie
and then like you'll have a general area
to find them and then you'll be able to
end up talking to them and that person
will have something for you if you
complete missions for that person so
it's going to be an experience I haven't
I haven't found this person yet either
all right cool questions for you because
I mean you know one all right what what
is this I did a project I'm doing a
project try getting those elements
they'd be asking for the water or
whatever whatever I build them whatever
they need ad book bags all that but then
they gave me some jointness like track
down some dude named eat head or
something and I went underground
underneath a manhole they want me for
the clean
let me I want to break down this super
chair this man is a genius
he's a painting to read it he be and at
the same time he just got in the Klan
all of them say out of the pocket I
don't gain more the weekend sorry that's
why we have to wake you up every morning
without being woke up nothing with you
is but this is new waiting for you to
get back to my life how about you add me
as an admin today you as the boss like
them do Downey's yeah that bounty so
there's there's a couple of different
things one you'll eventually meet this
guy by the name of Otis and he'll
actually be able to give you bow knees
through Intel Tech which you'll
eventually get from unlocking him from
one of the settlements but there's also
with the projects in the settlements
once you complete the projects give you
a big chunk of XP and then some of them
will also give you a bounty to go after
those bounty characters will are more
people that will give you more XP and
then on top of that though some of them
not all of them will be part of those 52
names people will drop the 52 playing
cards is a wrap yeah if you die or if
you don't get tuned within 15 minutes
it's done you're
oh no just come back also to come back
now everything on the map once they they
stayed here oh it's just you got to go
to that general area and then find them
it depends some people when you go to
their area you'll be able to clear them
killed a couple of mobs there and then
you'll move to another area kind of like
you're searching for them because that's
exactly there um yeah but you don't I
wouldn't worry too much about never
quote-unquote seeing them again because
like I said once you meet that guy Otis
who gives you the quests you'll be able
to do all of those missions again again
yeah the other trick is is that if
you're trying to get to level 30 and you
don't do any of your side missions yeah
we'll give you exactly 33 percent of a
level and eventually it gets to the
point where you just like kind of like
what am I gonna grind in in the clan Oh
to what you go to pretty much right and
then once you beat all the members you'd
saved all the side missions for later
because that XP grind gets so hard at a
level so you shout out to you shout to a
Marco style thing also says something
similar you know saying and that's
what's up so anyway yeah that's pretty
much it memory as far as that I mean I
think it's the end game for days man see
I've been telling people like this game
go steal your soul man if you got other
games that you want to play like you
play division right now it's gonna be a
wrap for you playing on the games right
now it's just that good and um yeah man
this is this is kind of like I'm on my
attic way right mom I told you so holy
you're there a lot of people you know
didn't I love that game you know it's
one of the things I told y'all this
thing was coming out y'all here on the
panel just people in general you know
I'm saying that this was coming
Ubisoft learns from their mistake you
know I'm saying no one listens to their
community and applies that fixes better
than them you know I mean and look we
got a true battle now for this little
shooter title you know saying is all
watch anthem I don't know what's gonna
happen now but man you gotta buckle up
and this is what it is
ooby cellphone I do King you will
appreciate the Phoenix edition statue I
will take a picture when I eventually
okay yeah this is useful shout out the
snail Doh and for purchasing a $250
package so what he got with his package
he has a 6 scaled doll that comes in
that as super premium sideshow has been
making six skill dolls for years right
now these um I don't call them toys I
call them dolls
um because they come with real clothing
we call it mixed-media right and they
come with real clothing they come with a
whole bunch of switch-out hands
beautiful guns the articulation in the
character the dolls or I think it's like
what 200 points of articulation us now
if I'm correct - I didn't even I didn't
even want to pull it out because the
thing was like I was like so worried
that I was gonna get dirty by taking
sticker right into a case so I um
automatically because he hit me in the
dam and I automatically send him over
the sideshow which they do have six
scale cases that are they come
completely encases so you can see like
oh I don't know if you can see one oh
you can you can see the harm lobo right
there right so those cases they're
smaller then they made for the six scale
size that you can put on top of a table
or on top of your dress or something and
they have built-in lights that you can
position to illuminate your character so
it's a one encapsulation indicator I
think it's like 60 bucks depending on
the size for the six scale but anybody
that wants that stuff and if you
purchased at $250 on package please make
sure you put it inside a case because
that is super premium so this case like
yeah you got like these little lights
and stuff that you can put plates yeah
it has lights in it at the bottom and at
the top and you can position the lights
towards the character once you polled
your character inside the case you close
it you seal it seals it from dust smoke
any harmful UV lights that come in
because it's tented
you want character moon um discolor your
character won't get dust on it and it
won't fade you know over time
awesome you know what I would put in
there what my my my
Charizard holographic Pokemon card real
quick next time I gotta bring this to
the pediatr attic they say and I we duck
in the writing this in at the writing
and it is bad can we talk about the
terrible writing of the lines in the
game and on some about sending you to DC
when you in the middle of a gunfight
what is he going in he say is it's bad
writing and write in art I just have one
thing I want to say to the dizzy you're
luckier nayad men me cuz I they don't
care about no guys you were writing guy
the writing is terrible it's horrible
I've got you know what in certain games
I just come to ignore it I I saw it and
I was like whatever
well for me it's one of those things
like I never play with you guys but
eventually I will play with you guys
that I don't care about the story in
this game right so yeah it's not great
there's nothing there's nothing amazing
about it at least so or you know you
have you you know you have your scarred
characters you're angry characters you
know everybody's a an archetype so yeah
it's not great at all and I don't think
it needs to be dizzy said that arc isn't
story based so what is art
cuz it's a performance based it's not
story based it's like rapid pace
I'm confused act like like the vision
got some world winning stories in
character I'm not even together though
yeah it listen we all know for the most
part this is some you know
post-apocalyptic style kind of you know
world going to crash I love it is the
money flew nobody what they say like
we're not gonna City I will say like
destiny story right now is in a way
better place anthem got a better story
arc makes a frost I try to watch that
stuff too when you listen to like the
villains monologues when you find the
like I love home caches and you listen
to the winner it's stupid who's like
what if I'm telling you the truth
what if I'm misdirecting you you'll
never you'll never know the other day no
one's gonna say act like the vicious
story I'm gonna practice make a good
scoring loot shooters and they're gonna
get their good they're gonna pay out cuz
of it shame for the people who are on an
train like let's be real life
Adam narrative ain't nobody's gripping
like that nobody liked to meet massage
oh and maybe you don't say like the
right most people couldn't even tell you
the character's name yes I don't care
what they talk about so you'll just shut
up and let me get in the suit let me get
a jab I just wanna fly light so let's
not act like a soaring superior only
people who can put they chest out on
writing the story right now is
definitely you know saying like right
now with the drifter trying the
invitation of the nine all that is crazy
that's lit right I can't destinies
currently in their bag wait did you just
say destiny as a story
oh that's these in a bag I'm putting it
out red is because Bungie understands
how to deal or look to live Nicator
today for an article going up by our own
ancient of frost - well reading
specifically out they ain't the
invitation of the nine y'all know me
y'all know I don't lose none of those
award shows I have a particular bias
towards them so Grammys or what it was
the other one on the Oscars whatever the
hell that they do writin for their go it
ended how about tremendous launch we'll
see if he continues it looks
feature-rich
crazy smooth it's been it's been a great
stuff will you be some we'll see if they
keep it up in and the lunar shooter Wars
Lord King who is out yo shout out the
Google at the GDC next week that they're
going to
do some stuff and listen if the
rumblings is true I don't really like
the speculation part too much about
everything but in the background they're
talking about seda is working with
Google now
articularly saw this title there's the
story and I ran when I put in the chat
very quickly this is my topic because if
you all understand I told you Microsoft
isn't exactly like that - hmm
Microsoft isn't the company that we want
it we want it Sega
all right so Microsoft is there by
default so Microsoft is always looked at
with that snide I would say good news is
like okay okay come you know type of
thing and now if it's true that Sega is
in bed with Google
this can be Sega's ultimate get back
they have the catalog of games you want
to play updated they have the catalog of
games that can get you to purchase a
system they have the ability to put
together and attract their system if
they're working a hand-in-hand with
Google to Google has a cache imagine
somebody with knowledge but no finance
and then they have a do with finance and
no knowledge there's some perfect
marriage if this is true what does that
do to the realm is there really that
much of a threat that's what I bring to
the table daddy said you cast to
electric boogaloo go read out of state
yogi Raymond eyeshadow let's get this
going back this is interest we had a lot
of developments going on like King said
you know obviously GDC next week the
rumors are piling up
let's get actual it's no soft I was so
soft on this like where you can't with
these rumors man as Google come are they
the threat that we need to be worrying
about I mean they're the threat if if
you're to believe that streaming is
truly the future and that all this talk
that people are saying I have about you
know consoles aren't going anywhere
which I truly believe
but I truly believe this as well that in
the back of their minds if they can ever
get streaming to the point where it
mirrors super closely the local
experience you think every they're gonna
there are companies and companies that
we love will try to go this route
exclusively why because the overhead is
just that much less like the amount of
money they'll be able to save we're just
giving you a platform as opposed to a
piece of hardware is immense like but it
always comes down to the bottom line
right but it also goes on the
feasibility is anybody who has a chance
besides Microsoft to really make the
streaming thing be a reality it's Google
that's why I still even despite all of
this stuff with you know partnering with
Sega with um with it being onstage with
them at GDC as well they were talking
about it's gonna be there and people are
assuming that that you know the next
doom is gonna launch day and date with
with the consoles and whatnot
for me it still feels like it they're
still talking about the project stream I
can honestly don't feel as a box
associated with this hold on so you
think that there's not gonna be a
dedicated console I mean II this it's
there's never been a moment in time
where for consoles couldn't coexist
feeling successful at the same time it's
tough so now how do you differentiate
yourself right how did it switch
differentiate itself it made itself a
portable thing like I just think just
and and even looking at streaming now
streaming is getting crowded right
everybody's getting into that so it you
know they and Microsoft are the one best
position to capitalize on this so when
honestly the thing about it that it's
interesting to me in the partnerships
the Sega's thing can still be a reality
because think ends to be a reality do
they think but I just think it's it's
about partnerships about maybe
exclusivity stuff oh I don't think it's
that because honestly why are you having
a GDC keynote yes you know and that's
and that's why I understand people's
thinking that it could still be a box
associated he showed off project stream
a lot of people played it already
not a face shine on the Lord mods or
Lords of gaming that net he's got an
article look they're about the specs man
half for the Xbox one X thing that's
that's a weird thing to me too because
if the sake of partnership is true then
something more powerful than the Xbox
one X falls into that same category that
the Dreamcast fell into when it launched
whether it was an in-between console
that was great but the next hotness was
right on its heels and I don't know that
they'd want to put themselves in that
scenario again I mean the owners like I
don't know man like that's why I don't
see it being a con sorry so slow
reacting they would hit it and it would
have been gone 10 minutes ago do y'all
like Facebook or your data gonna be sold
and preached go in the bushes Wow why I
think they do have a possibility of
doing something but at the same time
look what they done of youtube look what
they done with the Google Plus in it Wow
i'ma go edge you wouldn't need to be
only when you're streaming stuff so this
is true you're not lying
that can't be bad that's right let me
ask you what about these rumors we're
hearing like shout to the finest the
finest made you better hit that
application for Lords of gaming
nose but on the oh I was gonna say what
about the whole rumor or like I said the
saying a partnership now we're here in
Crystal Dynamics a made a whole bunch of
hires we're here about that Avengers
game remember back then like they talked
about that could possibly shown every
let me ask Atticus if they make some
solid game partnerships does that change
anything for you it depends on what you
mean by solid game going party could be
it like we know August off we know obese
off is gonna have some role there cuz
that didn't that they hired
what's-her-name Jade Raymond I believe
mom you know she was the former lead of
on Assassin's Creed franchise you know
say she's also was on Splinter Cell so
you're going to be this she's been hired
by Google
we know Phil Harris Minh aka everyone's
VP at some point from Microsoft and and
Sony who's been a president at one point
he is also now VP then leading the game
division also aka the other Phil it
depends on what their approaches they
call unless a Phil mmm when it comes to
what kind of platforms they're gonna
like I don't think Sega is gonna be
known I think I got a lot of great IPS
that they could do wonders with mmm-hmm
but I think that you know they're gonna
have to have something more that appeals
to you know my generation as well and
they've got to get something to appear
so like my brothers generation is I
think right now they got that that those
IPS that appeal to that you know
anywhere from 30 to 45 range okay and I
don't I think you know they got the
money to do it there's no denying that
they could go in there and probably by
publishers that's what Andy got that
Brad just so Microsoft knows they really
want to go in you know at the end of the
day they've always had a a way of
thinking that gets them in trouble oh my
gosh please talking please
[Laughter]
I could even acknowledge that but it
just depends on what they do like I mean
look at it from a standpoint they run
you - how many issues do we have with
YouTube and we have no one a contact but
like they love dropping the ball in so
many areas like like sure they might put
mad amounts of money into this into this
into this industry and then a year from
now they drop it because I didn't do
what they wanted this like I mean the
talk around this is they've been working
on developing this platform or whatever
it is for the better part of a decade
like so they're they're in they just
needed to figure out how to get in hmm
so I don't think they're this is
whatever it is I don't think it's
slipshod I really thought yeah I think
they have a good chance because I don't
think that Sega would be the only one
that they would do it with yeah I think
that there's too many IPs and too many
now you know who they need a bot oh that
are THQ Nordic they can think all they
need that would be it I'll be conquered
let me get this I would King let yo
Tuesday is gonna be interesting
like nineteen buckle up Yoji DC's coming
y'all man I mean solve you played the
project stream right and you felt yo it
was you know it was what's up we got
that we got the leak controller and I'm
saying we sort of patents for that we've
seen the Phil Harrison higher we seen
Jade Raymond as the VP like I said
Assassin's Creed lead it's been a sell
the sake of rumors this Crystal Dynamics
rumor with the Avengers game you know I
don't know what to believe what to say
good thing know cuz it's like I still
find it hard to believe if that happens
you know saying but you know i'ma say
good kid you know say so I can't I can't
get mad if it go down
but I'm which solving this respect I
can't envision a market with for
consoles like you come on for that's a
lot you know Sam but I get we would say
this they got the capital they're
extremely aggressive you know if you
look at it it kind of reminds you king
of a young Microsoft cuz mama Microsoft
they had no business
jumping in the game and a few people
like you know what did they do remember
mmm-hmm
so we got that the key to me for
Google's amoenus games will they have
true exclusives right will project
stream be downloadable for local play
because I think it's the L sort of
extreme only I think that's the L now we
know many are still resistant to the
streaming thing I get it you know I'm
saying but the long-term commitment and
the power Spencer this is where I agree
with attic like they got one thing about
Microsoft right with OG xbox they took
that elf from a financial standpoint but
it was kind of just to get in the game
right but the difference between
Microsoft and Google is Microsoft stuck
with it
right and then aggressively came back
with the d6 they kind of ended their own
era
okay Bowie jumped in without a lot of
companies after the original Xbox they
were just like you Brad we've done
exactly so the thing is if things go
south early right with Google with all
the power they have and I'm saying what
are they going to you know I'm saying
cuz otherwise it's gonna be the new 3do
with turbo graphics no but like okay
what you say so and that's what I that's
what I think about if they it's actually
actually a piece of hardware I could
easily seeing and being besides the
streaming um it being a game past type
service where you're downloading as well
if you have the capabilities to do that
right I mean I think that's all fun and
dandy but like as of right now unless
you're you know unless you go out and go
to PC I don't see a lot of people just
willingly if not the fact that people
aren't going to do it it's the fact that
it's not the norm people are used to
building pcs to play games on PCs
they're not used to to go into a web
browser and playing games on a web
browser well we see that it could be
something that could be built to the
minds they easily and that could really
go out for them because everyone's got
access to a browser absolutely I mean
listen at the same time also the
competitive everybody streaming now like
that's the new thing like we see you
Microsoft loading up on all fronts you
got the game studios they yeah they got
the X cloud the azure Xbox Live with the
best online infrastructure switches in
pocket you know I'm saying what they're
hybrid space you know I'm saying they
got a powerful eye
and all that and then you know the
rumors are still that Microsoft and them
with game packs might still link up if
the ink dries or maybe they're just not
ready to announce it right now and we
still got so do like slowly the de facto
leader Jen so they got the huge momentum
they got the cash cow IPS with sequels
they just sitting on so what a push of a
button they could be like spider-man to
God or whatever you got I'm saying like
horizon zero dawn whatever like they're
sitting on stuff we know the back compat
is coming just whether or not it's gonna
be paid for that that's reserved then we
got you know ps5 hardware you know
they're going beasts so shout out the
Lord months cuz um they said he had that
great Google article on Lords of gaming
that net but um you know the whole thing
is like if projects ringing it's rumored
to be more powerful than the ex then
even though that's good it could be a
situation with king of saying where's
like yeah you're like a you're like a
Dreamcast right you're better than like
it's gonna be like no no that you don't
want to beat me again
right it so again which could mean short
term L right which is you jump right
back to you I'm almost done you jump out
it's a it's a it's a decent showing but
then ultimately it doesn't do what they
do now will they have the Microsoft in
them to say okay let's reinvest let's
double down because at the end of the
day you got ps5 gonna be out there you
got lock if it's not more powerful than
lock court that's gonna be a problem
yeah I'm saying no lock or it is I mean
my thing is Tom's gonna tell how serious
they truly are you know say or if they
fold up like you know Google+ when they
try to challenge Facebook is time tell
we're gonna see how real it is you know
I'm saying in a minute but Tuesday I'm
told they're making this your topic well
okay um we all know Google was
juggernaut globally right so cashwise
they won't be strapped now will the
higher-ups
see the benef
in a gaming division that's the question
now will they be able to make all of
those services that they have with
Google into the system to shoe on at the
Trojan horse it ok what what like
Microsoft these big companies want to
Trojan horse their system to you to give
you services see everybody is
complaining that microsoft offers all of
these services and they boy where's the
games the games are coming but these
services are here now once you start
engaging in all these services like
buying your movies in this one spot
watching your shows in this one spot if
you have your xbox on you're watching
YouTube
you're still engaging through your xbox
right now if they I believe they're
gonna give you a system if they said the
system is more powerful than X and it
has a better CPU whoa now they're not in
the same position as the Dreamcast thing
because remember they said the Lockhart
is gonna come in under the PlayStation
right but then you also have that akanda
that's over that right and the
PlayStation is like right there in that
middle what if this is right there in
that middle on par with the PlayStation
with the PlayStation 5 yeah but now the
PlayStation has the pedigree and the
games and this is what will keep them
afloat
what can offset that another company
that they have a catalog of games and a
strategy and know-how that has been
dominant in the game in general this is
why I say Sega is very important if true
because Sega can help them with strategy
in areas they have no idea about so they
won't be coming in blindfolded like
Microsoft filling away in the dark
trying to feel a way in they will
actually hit the ground running with the
knowledge of say this is why I say they
a credible threat and will people
purchase the system hell today yes I
will purchase it turbo graphics was my
greatest system know if they turbo
graphics yes I'll take that please let
me get one of
and one down here in the back so but
here's the thing like so officer do you
think that is sustainable like no in
this type of a market like somebody
can't survive right nobody Oh has got oh
you don't say like for we've seen we've
been around you know the noise enough to
know that during that turbo I mean it
was in the beginning right it was was it
yet Sega Super Nintendo whatever we had
cuz doctor bro came out was the 16-bit
era right mm-hmm
yeah Genesis turbo Super Nintendo and
that was it right there a serious
question for you Google came in and they
had a console that really did well who
would you who would you expect to go to
Sony mmm I can't go as much as I hate to
say this I'd have to say Microsoft like
like is two apps you're looking at that
PlayStation now they're gonna be an app
and you looking at Microsoft game
services as an app they date the both
those two will be out the door Nintendo
I shown you they can withstand any guy
they're going thing and they don't care
about what's going on in the world to
them they're in a bubble they will put
out a system that will do for IT people
actually outsell that Google thing so I
don't worry about Nintendo ever sorry
the chosen one but you're able to back
with that a VP I'm telling you right now
those two will die I mean listen sorry
you have a race it's a four-man race who
falls I think the one who's most willing
to do it would be Microsoft willing to
do it because of everything else they
put into place I think all right all
right then let's take it from a
standpoint of whose legacy did you
personally would want to continue I
don't care I don't I mean the hardware
stuff
no I talk about games everything no
games see I don't think anybody's legacy
goes in terms I think games the games
will continue whether it be through a
service an Apple whatever I think
everyone's legacy is sustained in that
regard in terms of the hardware I think
Microsoft would be the ones will be most
apt to go or
being in in the best place to go without
hindering their overall legacy in so
there's another fact that we now did
talk a mine this is the Sony included we
have to talk about the fact that even
Shawn Layden Sony themselves said he
envisions a console list future right so
all of them long term for streaming and
in that Deborah so maybe we're looking
at it different maybe we're looking at
it from an antiquated standpoint that
the console is necessary because that's
all we know up until this point that's
why I'm sorry I'm know is a streaming
was like to me it becomes down to who
now control streaming right I think
services and streaming is extremely
important but regardless what it comes
down to it's always gonna be about the
exclusive content on these services
I mean look look at Netflix Netflix
wouldn't be where it is without the
Marvel ip's they've done their without
the the house of cards like these
services that's why Microsoft's bought
so many studios cuz they still need
games to put on these survey here's the
thing people not talking about and again
I'm not again we just look at it if this
is the new future and everyone's
yearning for streaming this console
that's war right now the reality is we
don't know what Sony's streaming future
really is right it would have to admit
based on the information we know right
now unless until we hear something with
Sony partnering with somebody as of
right now they don't have the long term
everything infrastructure set up the way
of who will have an amount of right
we're just gonna act like Nintendo has
anything set up like that right true but
here they will agree that Nintendo don't
care if they're in their own bag right
there in their own pocket there in this
portable space that they do not care
what anyone else is doing they've shown
time and time again that they're gonna
do beat to their own drum no one thought
switch was gonna tell me I even think
switch was gonna do what it's doing so
this little portable hybrid space is
very unique for them and let's be real
the rumors are that they're partnering
with Microsoft
right at some point that we know right
now that Microsoft and Nintendo are
working on something they just impasse
is gonna be on their Google Microsoft
playing in and grabbing them up in them
to team and if anything and I could see
what Google would be is I don't
necessarily think it's gonna be a
college so I think it's gonna it's it's
gonna be on her browser where you'll
click on it we don't store yeah I think
it's gonna have its own store you'll be
able to play anything and you know I can
even see you know game pass and stuff
going to that so let's get this less
less because next week is coming we will
have some final facts by next week
before the next show so I say that I
propose that we do oh yeah or nay all
right although that think there's going
to be a system shown an actual physical
system let's get that yay yeah I got the
yeah a physical system
I got a name I got a name against no I I
said hey I said no in making for the
record Tuesday the 19th GDC Auto you
know I'm gonna say yeah you know the
reason I'm gonna say yeah is because
there there has been a lot of
controllers kinematics and stuff leads
and I wouldn't necessarily be there
without a console to go with it so I'm
gonna say yes say yay and no wolf once
again yes you used to be this after job
Hey
well according to King according to King
I'm on their side so you have a pretty
good chance of winning this because I
wasn't losing everything here you will
see what happens but yeah console wars
been heating up great topic Lord King
anything else you got on that before we
roll to next say good please cyber good
to virtual blame it yeah I could show
Lord song Xbox Live coming to other
things yeah coming to other things is
correct
so last week Microsoft announced at my
soft and head of Xbox Live Adam
McCullough announced that Microsoft was
Xbox was bringing the Xbox Live SDK to
iOS and Android so basically you could
apply the underpinnings of Xbox Live
achievements party chat all that stuff
that you used to seeing on Xbox Live can
now be applied to Android and iOS games
as the developer see fit oh that's
important in that that that is to be
again another sign of Microsoft's
tentacles going everywhere and making
sure that the underlying guts of crazy
so yeah I mean it's what it is it's the
beginnings of getting that Xbox Live
infrastructure on everything um and it
honestly the Xbox Live stuff
specifically for Android and iOS is kind
of the smaller announcement within the
bigger announcement so the bigger
announcement is that with the Xbox Live
um SDK stuff for iOS and Android is part
of a bigger package which Microsoft is
called Microsoft game stack or game
stack is is a suite of all of their
services Xbox Live Direct X mixer simply
gone as your play fab everything that
encompasses what you need to development
a platform someone turn off this man's
my camera crazy over here looks like
he's into it looks like he's harassing a
neighbor your boss will say cake busted
out the break-in to lose
you look like that rapper trying to sell
a CD out the back first clearly King is
ready to talk so did this is the huge
announcement right because this suite of
services basically gives any and every
developer on any platform the tools to
integrate all of these services in all
of their games in all the versions of
their games across all platforms
seamlessly this is really what they
wanted to get at right especially when
you look at what you know epic trying to
get into the game now Google trying to
get into the game and especially epic
when they talked about how do you how do
you create a better environment for
developers right how to make things
developer friendly you know obviously
with the with the the smaller cut that
they're taking this big but also access
to the Unreal Engine um and and those
tools so they realize the importance of
giving developers easy tools to work
with allowing them to integrate all of
their games and all of the services that
their games utilize across all platforms
and this is what this game stack is it
is huge and even bigger than the iOS and
Android Xbox Live stuff because that's
encompassed within this the game stack
is really what is what back back when we
first started talking about the sort of
stuff we talked about um what the heck
it was called Tim Sweeney was beefing
about it um the development platform for
Xbox and PC that was being used across
the board this is actually exactly is
that you wwp so this is basically a huge
encapsulation of that of all of every
single one of those services under one
umbrella it's huge and and if everybody
adopts it the way Microsoft is hoping
and when it comes to people utilization
like the cloud and stuff like that if
people adopt either the way they hope
they will with this sort with this
package it's gonna be huge 4x cloud and
Microsoft's just sort of
involvement in platforms across the
board moving forward his whole video he
said he was gonna do that I see your iOS
and I raise you some Android Dominus out
here swinging his petty at you again
check it out the we all had moving and
shaking baby all you you just really got
shook up just sake Alan I listened to
all of you check it out
he just said put that on everything
nothing excluded my phone is down with
that
check that out Alan got iOS as well when
y'all talking Apple that you cut the
crowd in half you over there could play
again solely with the non friendly stuff
again somebody's left out with Sony you
left that was only not me Microsoft said
you know what yo King man we will put
our services out on everything now as
far as I'm sorry you saying that Sony
hates Android users no let's just say
Sony is always half button things half
button things you know I can't curse on
the show so you understand what I'm
saying it's always half but go Full Tilt
don't have told don't stick one foot in
the water jump in the pool and stop
playing so much sauce that we gonna give
you the whole services now what might
work we're sovereign didn't tell you is
all those services interact with each
other and connect so if you use that
service right that's saying you plan on
PC they want you to be able to connect
through your PC through your switch and
everybody playing together mm-hmm if if
the developer allows it and it's up to
the developer what platform he puts
those games on he could make that one
game that plays with
everybody hmm okay so no moral yeah use
those tools providing they use those
tools is like a switch like they hit the
switch what was the stuff that we was
talking about before cross play cross
progression right that's that so they're
trying to eliminate all the barriers
that's keeping us separated
remember how you have different systems
all set up they are trying to get to
that one utopia that we've always talked
about oh you know we can play together
as you saw how PD said oh he's over here
smell both said he's over here on PC
well that won't happen if I'm playing on
whatever platform and I'm playing on
with this Microsoft a strategy in tech
I'll be playing with snailed Oh mm-hmm
keeping my progression going mmm not
being definitely some good points there
man let me jump in there this is one
world government King is that giving it
up to the Lord
Xbox only begotten Son already you know
they prophesized it to be looks better
this is just more more of everything you
know what they've been saying you know
it's no surprise like this is what
they've been maybe wanting to do for a
long time he said every device you know
that III there's nothing new to me um my
only question Nosa was like the
long-term thing with the - because you
know we know what xbox live you know
being on ios and android that's dope but
my thing is what incentive does a dev
have to use the tools in the mobile
space you know I'm saying cuz it's like
to switch I understand it you never
saying because they you know they're big
but they're not really moving out there
and it's clear that they've been using
SDK you know I'm saying to try to
improve on that level if they like stuff
like that again my article gear down
that check it out
but um yeah man at the end of the day
it's like what's the incentive because
because mobile market is its own little
beast right so I gotta see how they
attack that you know honestly I think
specifically to that point I think it's
more about games as you know like all
these phones are getting more and more
powerful they're easily a lot of xbox
live games maybe 360 games maybe game
they require you know less processing
power something something along the
lines of an Ori or maybe a cup head or
something like that that can be actually
sold as a full download on a phone like
these razors phones that are coming up
now super powerful so I think it's with
that in mind not necessarily I mean they
giving you the option right to retrofit
it to older older games and obviously to
new games coming to the mobile market so
I don't know I don't know if that's
really the target for it they just
giving you the option for it but I think
this is with eyes on being able to put
actual actually what we call you know
core games where these platforms I guess
my thing is the flip direction the flip
side right because mobile space is like
when I think of mobile I think of like
candy crush and right in combat so like
let's just say Microsoft trying to get
their hand in this right in the pocket
and giving these devs that that tool to
make the next one like my thing is
what's the incentive cuz they really
wasn't doing it before you know I'm
saying with what was available I they
really like number one Windows 10 phone
was out it really wasn't so my thing is
is this like I'm curious to know shout
the Xbox too they had a great point jazz
chord had a great point on it's like cuz
he actually talked to Korean Chaudhary
who's running this that he's head of the
other Aboriginal stuff and he's the one
promoting the stack and play fab and all
this SDK so and it's great I just want
to know how they pitch it to the mobile
guy to say hey here's the incentive to
use this to have the Xbox Live feature
to have that stack to have all that
great these great features and actually
create games from the ground up cuz I
would like to see those developers crate
games from the ground up on the mobile
side cuz to me that's the advantaged in
because they start making the next candy
crush or a modern combat whatever it is
and it's with that stack then Microsoft
really benefits you know say I'm not
saying it won't benefit the other
direction I'm saying for sure but I just
think I think the mobile space is a
little different is that this is not my
bag but I I do get a little different
cure to see I think I think the key
thing in the entire game stack for
Microsoft Azure is as you if everything
obviously if they can develop the entire
game from the ground up using the tools
in game stack is great but for I think
for Microsoft the key thing is for them
to utilize Azure as their cloud-based
day and I think that's where the you
incentivize them like okay if you use
Azure to proliferate this game across
all platforms right if you want to put
it on iOS if you eventually want to move
it over to Xbox for you know in it in a
different form or PlayStation in a
different form it's all built in there
already you don't have to do a lot and
that to me is the selling point where if
you use Azure as the backbone of it mmm
you're gonna be everywhere with no
problem wait and I think that speaks
that you know when it when you talk
about the bottom line and how much you
have to spend I think that speaks you
know that speaks stronger than anything
else to these developers it's
interesting a hand in there man that's
all I got solvers good you go yeah it's
funny like if you go today the game
stacks um page what they do is that they
have they have a little blurb right
describing what it is right they have
they have certain words in the blurb
that stay the same right we can help you
stays the same and add to your stays the
same game and run it on and then those
other words that are missing they just
keep swapping in and out different words
to show how malleable this like the
entire service is like we can help you
automate your tournaments and your Punk
racing game and then they could and you
can run it on an arcade you can run it
on a Playstation you can run it on a
switch they're swapping these words in
and out to show that it really is an
all-in-one sort of solution yeah listen
it sounds great
all of it sounds fantastic I love what
King is talking about as far as this
unified ecosystem where there's fewer
berries - fewer fewer barriers to entry
right I love I just want to see the
implementation I just want to see how
they make it attractive for everyone to
actually utilize stuff but it is it's
super promising like definitely hear
what you guys saying but we are going to
move on so ah yes I'm up so um Project X
cloud
oh yeah so are we
this has been out here in these streets
you know and the questions are you know
was on inside Xbox you know and the
streets are buzzin right now because the
question are was this live demo of the X
cloud Fugazi that's a so the questions I
got to before cuz I got a lot to say on
this and i'ma let y'all rock but one
cool on the panel sort with the
relatives or it and to if you did see it
do you agree with the masses that this
demo was staged or faked so who saw it I
saw it yes I did see you I wanted to go
first
Lloyd add it now that you have seen it
do you agree with the masses that the
project X cloud demo was staged a fake
yes I do
okay I just don't see from what she was
doing was was is either a it was fake or
be the input lag makes that not play and
I think I'm going with the left I got a
call from man like I did it she didn't
put her hand on the right analog stick
once during the entire demo I you know
that that was a red flag for me I was
just like what was going on she's just
hitting the triggers and using the L and
it doesn't even seem to be in
conjunction with what I'm seeing on the
phone like there were some movements
like she was making there were slight
movements on the game that didn't
correspond with the bigger movement she
was making on the analog stick it just
it just didn't mm-hmm and then and then
it another thing is like you've already
showed in your announcement trailer you
showed you showed four
already show some cows mmm
Lord King Project X cloud oh when she
acts surprised it was yeah there you go
another thing
she kept tapping left on the analogue
and I was like the kind even going left
I said that's the same video you show
before I'm sorry I'm very a steep not
stupid
my thing is if you don't have nothing
live this show stop being called out on
dumb things like stop shop stop trippin
yourself up on foolery maybe the the the
technology is there in you just there
one morning YouTube video you know how
to hit them have it something really
goes wrong
Oh God you can't oh no we can't do that
Jordan face meme all week so I think I
think literally the only part that could
have been worse than what we saw is that
they were playing like Uncharted on that
thing you know what they should've did
they should have played something else
just like just like they said they
should have played something else play
some Co thieves play somethin play
somethin play don't play crackdown cuz
you probably not crack yo X now so I
honestly believe in I thought that they
learn their lesson with the bad showings
the poor act them pity with with the
narrative if you're gonna do a Nintendo
you're gonna control the narrative
why don't you really control a narrative
see where Sony has behind certain things
this is where Microsoft half behind
their stuff when it comes to presenting
things they have always those up you are
your worst enemy get rid of these dudes
in your uh your PR team get rid of them
all take them out and release them into
the wild
don't bring them back listen when they
go to swipe in their card make sure it's
deactivated go to the password make sure
it doesn't work
don't let them show up to work any
longer send them in check and send them
home get in real people just let me give
you real advice and be real with you so
you can honestly do this for real
because this you know you had a platform
that you was going to show this X Club
you messed up your damn delivery it was
garbage let me jump in right because
this is oh all right all right
remember when you play the telltale game
attic and you make a bad choice in the
game and the dialog box
it'd be like such as such will remember
that no akkad leader will remember all
right first off for the record I believe
in the tech I believe in a project ice
cloud but in my opinion I do my mop up
my batiatus voice what again
presentation gods have failed me then
you have family now here's the deal I
did some diction I did a lolly HD she's
going crazy I did some digging behind
the scenes a handful my sources it was
real you know saying now he shout out
their lady Julia Hardy she's co-hosting
this and sign Xbox event and shouts in
woman's mom team salute
but low-key this I asked my guys the
women were doing a better hosting that's
another story anyway just say yes
whether it's her using that feathering
force of control style because I heard
that's a thing I'm saying I'm not gonna
disrespect anybody skill level at the
game or just the stress of playing the
game live while interviewing at the end
of the day even though I got
confirmation that it was real right I
still blame Microsoft you already know
the skepticism
day in and day out about how people
think this tech is for gazing many
people think streaming is not the future
so you gotta have an air-tight demo
of this tech when it's gonna be laughs
I'm with King like put her in position
to win so now unfortunately Tech is
getting all type of criticism it's gonna
easily been avoided
people screaming fake freak and you know
I'm saying and I can't get mad at that
based on what how it appeared right I'm
not and I'm not gonna let it go like
this is a big deal like this is a hue of
the future I'm gonna get you at it like
this is a huge part of the future Xbox
they're banking on this to sell the
masses like presentation gods like I've
been on you're not like it's not even
it's no it's no comparison to something
like the last two e threes I get it yeah
I got better but when it comes to this
inside Xbox fan I need better I need
better I'm sorry I need better because
for my understanding the tech works for
my understanding it is real you know I'm
saying
but that's showing that doesn't help
y'all at any of it it sucks because now
everybody looking at it with the coroner
right reason to have it that stays and
listen I've come to accept what inside
Xbox is I honestly I'm not mad at the
show or the format of it anymore like
they you know it really is inside Xbox
they want you to show you the ins and
outs of things that as gamers you never
see or maybe don't even care about and I
think it's cool in that respect because
I think no other company does that with
a it wants you to know the people that
work there the things that they do out
I've accepted that and I'm cool with
that
what I don't like is is this this staged
presentation stuff that comes off as
it's in genuine for and I think that
that's a perfect example like she
obviously knew it was coming why do you
have to make this whole song and dance
around it making it seem like it's some
surprise my thing is that I'm getting
real tired of is never get tired of I
personally don't care but at the end of
the day it's like look at the comic
thing that happened last year of
crackdown that hurt crackdown as a whole
friend it's like if you're going to let
people like no fits to anyone at the
comic-con if you don't let people that
don't play games test your game don't
publicize it like it's a demonstration
of your game
oh hold on I gotta jump
try gonna shut up Chris Belisle shot the
black bear tactics
bug I'm not nitpicking like it if listen
at the end of the day you can't say that
it looked real that's what I'm trying
even though I've got confirmation so
ain't nobody over here echo chamber and
anything black bear tactics the whole
thing is again the tech from my
understanding is real but if I'm gonna
look at it solely on what was displayed
I can see the argument everyone's gonna
say yo that look for gays II that look
fake like that's all I'm trying to say
so they gotta put her in a control the
ROM or something like where they're
allowed to do it not rushed where she's
talking and do it all or whatever it is
they got a showcase that better that is
your tech that you are trying to sell to
the masses you cannot it you know they
have probably 50,000 people watching
that live now you have 50,000 people
that potentially told their friends that
that's fake that you have their friends
telling their friends it's fake that's
one for you know you have another 2013
on your heads that no one believes in
this product that's all I'm saying the
joy could be legit real it is just like
you oh yeah doing it to yourself that's
all I'm saying and even and even let's
say okay let's say it is real right even
if it is real right it's still not the
best one simply because you're putting
it in the most ideal of situations
you're controlling the internet you're
controlling everything everything is is
perfectly controlled by you it's still
not the best one you really want to show
this off the people have to have the
alpha the Alpha of the bait or whatever
half people have it in their hands and
touch it for themselves and have that
conversation inform people's opinion of
it still something that you can't if you
cannot show in a controlled setting X
leave it what I woulda did was instead
of giving her the controller mmm just
have a few people in the crowd yeah walk
out randomly give the controller to
somebody but I can't do that just in
case you do go yeah this is it and there
you go again that's the thing that's
that's the crux that's what I'm talking
about so if it's not ready to do that
you don't view this that in that right
question like if that was the case then
they shouldn't have shown it at all like
to be honest when we billion in projects
allowed to be shown now I'm happy they
attempted it but if you're going to
attempt it you have to do it right
was that a preemptive strike at Google
formic acid shot again I want to shout
out the Xbox too because um again just
going there and man they've been on it
and they literally said the same thing
because the question is why now right
mm-hmm
Oh talk to the last topic we know who's
coming on Tuesday I mean who's doing
project stream on Tuesday it's just a
matter of whether or not they're gonna
add a console to it right so that's why
I was like why did they feel the need to
do this now and again I'm not trying to
put julia harden out there you know I'm
saying it's just again you've got to put
this tech in position to win this thing
gotta be flawless it gotta pause to get
show true functionality like don't just
hand her a joint in the middle while
she's talking and you gotta do this
right man I would've crashed into a wall
I woulda did a burnout you were just
sort of my controller doing what it do
and do that mmm yeah I mean that's all I
got on it like I said I still personally
believe in the tech I still think
project as cloudy I'm sorry one thing
they should have focused on also is the
fact that to this point Google has not
talked about any sort of wireless
functionality with their service it's
only been hardwired they did not stress
the point that hey we're running this on
4G right now this isn't 5g yeah that
would have gone a long way to also be
like okay you know what they trying
today they're getting this to actually
work somewhat on current tech which is
something that Google has not even
attempted they haven't even talked about
anything because all of their wireless
stuff in regards to project stream it's
completely relying on 5g and they
haven't talked at all about that it's
only been wired Ethernet connections you
know what I'd have been happy with off
if there'd just be like look don't show
it right but I go the public beta trials
start on this date we're gonna start you
know I'm saying giving these out and
getting these and so then you give
people like us or whoever you know
and Jeffrey in porn and we out there
rocking and rolling into universe saying
and did people like yo such a says play
played it or saw played it like then it
becomes a thing right because these are
from different a pax thing yeah you know
I'm saying make some project cloud game
change do something but do not do that
again I'm not blaming the tech I'm
blaming the presentation the
presentation was not a goal and this has
been the Achilles heel like King said
for this whole generation they've got to
tighten up that's all I'm saying
so I'm not gonna get it right I know and
they've run out of time because like I
said we know who's coming Tuesday and we
know next-gen DS we can't have these
snafus man we can't it's too many times
and I give them credit the last two e
threes on but inside Xbox the bushes for
me you need to put those people that you
got on the e3 team to those dudes
changed a passcode please they'll say we
get it to the last table this is real
quitters be like a news lab I know
addicts got to get out of here
so all yeah man um this is I'm gonna
actually flew something different so I'm
just doing run up a couple of news
topics and we're gonna do Lourdes gave
him a throne edition this is epic round
two you know is this so first off on the
sea side you know I'm saying we got halo
Master Chief collection right Wow who
would've thought you know we know coming
to PC but we got to admit like the steam
announcement was huge like no one saw it
is so it's like you know to see them to
kind of playing nice together for the
first time we want to see what happens
with the future of that right then we
got more rumors now on an epic side
we've heard that our Borderlands 3
there's a possibility we hear get
gearbox kind of chirping a little bit on
we did here which was actually another
huge announcement as far as on epic and
reference to the game store like they've
made a lot of changes remember a lot of
things that are me an adequate talking
about where you know they're in the
beginning stages so it looks like they
set out a road map so when April and May
they talking about cloud saves all these
functionality things that the steam
store actually has and it's a huge like
PowerPoint presentation so we got that
going
now I want to talk about the night sugar
you know and they're not so good
obviously is on epic there's been
there's been accusations accused of them
spying on your your stream data so if I
say the spyware at the epic stuff look
and see what's going on you know I said
and then on the other thing that came
out on addict should know if not addict
remember the creator of the original
XCOM arm now this link in explain yeah
again alright so it looks like Phoenix
point so it looks like at the last
minute kind of like a ashen and kind of
like a metro this is now an epic store
exclusive you know and so yet another
one epic stores coming in snatching up
and you know prior to that the community
thought it was you know coming to UM
what's called the Peter steam not a you
know the developer had to come out and
make a statement and try to explain
what's going on cuz it was backlash so I
want to bring this to the Lord so you
know I'm saying it's a lot of moving is
shaking going on between epic and steam
right now and I want to know Game of
Thrones edition your say like who's
winning this war which I think all this
news coming out yeah I'm winning this
war
why are you winning this mu addict
because steam is losing more and more
momentum you missed that one completely
dude is rightfully Microsoft putting
them games on Steam attic like that door
would have thought Master Chief
collection on Steam me told you listen
Phil has been showing you little by
little if you check out them breadcrumbs
he had that steam shirt on so he's been
leading you down the hallway just to let
you know the doors that way and we open
the doors a whole new world so all that
stuff that you see right now steam is
more apt to get down a lay down right
now because you got big boy breathing on
a neck right now so they they give it
low prices like who is this new dude in
this block
give it low price
on the same stuff I'm selling yeah what
is something let me ask you this King do
you dig Game of Thrones right now mm-hm
I'm a Microsoft you never really played
that nice we know the games have been
like the killer instinct and a couple
181 of the game but they never had the
Xbox Live functionality like Master
Chief is about to have on Steam and this
is Microsoft now say hey we'll give you
that cut X team is feeling that pressure
and like yo we gotta les lake you don't
say that the common thug I told you a
long time ago when you're losing you're
doing anything to get back on top yo you
over got a pay cut and you trying to
figure out how can I get my paycheck
back now you yeah have you ever got yo
yo check right and you say let's say you
check every week was like 950 then you
got a pay cut knew that 750
so you started doing overtime to get
back to that 950 because you're out of a
comfortable lifestyle at 950 right so
these dudes is doing overtime now now
they got to get out here and play with
people they don't normally play with to
get back to the Bucs didn't usually get
learn to shut out the lure a team and
crew he said Phil Bethany the Lord gave
it yeah you know what listen you can
assume how you want to view that but I
want you to understand this right
somebody had to say yes please bring
that over here
who's really bending in me see this is
how to puppet master works mmm he lets
you think you're in control till he yank
you string so you think he chose your
horse that once they start playing think
about it this way all these little
Master Chief heads these little Lou
Master Chief heads is gonna be playing
right with Xbox functionality again
engagement goofball who really build him
in me and I will say this no I mean we
know that it's a staggered release so
one thing that's interesting is that you
know they're doing reach first then
another marketing cycle with the first
Halo it's like a ghost XO each time it's
gonna be in front of that steam store is
on front as far as marketing promotion
and then
almost set up infinite in a way right
cuz they'll mean how to come over solve
like what you think do you dig Microsoft
and Steam playing nice is setting
something up bigger and they're looking
at epic as a threat or wait wait yeah
you don't pay them no mom I think you
know me I finally jump into the
conspiracy theories but I'm not on the
go they they were rumors about Microsoft
perhaps grabbing up steam right yes and
at that point we were like okay maybe if
gave once to just sell and doesn't feel
like just you know making money hand
over fist anymore like whatever like he
just wants to sell and get out of the
business okay
now you find steam in a position where
they're being attacked on two on two
fronts and now it's like okay whether
whether or not their position you know
into money-wise or whatnot is
diminishing it that's up for debate but
obviously they there are things they
have to change in order to continue to
look appealing when epic um is doing
what they're doing and this Court is
doing what they don't right so yeah you
know I wouldn't put it you know Phil I
feel putting the arm around Gabe and you
know me I'm not into the conspiracy
theories but it makes it makes sense
that that this is the time you know he's
there in the time of need has the
targaryen scum over to the with the fell
Jaime Lannister v-line oh man the white
walk is a common man I'm leaving you
behind I mean is it is it Google is
Google the well as Steve or not I think
it it's Google you have to be worried
about right obviously Tuesday's a big
deal um I'm gonna be honest yesterday I
purchased the game on the on the epic
game store they had a epic pad epic at a
sale with Ubisoft right and they had
watchdogs too for like eight bucks oh
wow
so I said let me get washed up stick
with that I had it on my ex but I
haven't played it so I'm like you know
what really let me just play it on a PC
so I got it and then if you look at the
launcher and Thor games launcher in the
store is super rudimentary at this point
still like it's very like it doesn't
have a lot of functionality at all so
when it gave me the option to actually
play the game through you play I was
like all right fine I'm gonna download
it through you play I purchased it on
the epic game store closed that and then
did everything else to do you play so
they're not quite there yet right they
still need to make those big deals to
bring people over obviously we have
heard everything that they're doing I'm
sure there are plenty of people who have
deals in the works yet smaller indie
developers maybe even some bigger
developers that still that stuff hasn't
come to light yet but because of how
developer friendly their practices are
we are gonna see more of that it's just
a matter of how much and is it enough to
really steamroll steam right to chat
with the game with chrome purposes they
said bill raise Khaleesi ride the blood
brothers said he's ride the back of the
Dragon they oughta could show but I will
say this to your point solving reference
to the store cuz one of the arguments
against epic was like people like yeah
we're not feeling I just buying games
right and get y'all store together now
there's a legit road map of all the
clown saying all the problems that not
all but I would say like maybe 75% of
the problems that people have with the
store in comparison steam they doing
knowings day and they put that map out
they're like yo we are going to address
this and this is within what year 1 I
don't know so so the question is whether
they really do if they do do that and
they are able to do it in that timeframe
or less and obviously less is better
right they can get that stuff up and
running as fast as possible it's huge
because then they then at that point you
really are competitor you're in the same
exact space you have the same exact or
better functionality and you don't you
have more eggs in your basket um it's
just a matter of how how willing people
are gonna be to adopt it but I know
they're gonna fight in that fight
they're not stopping
so all as to what steam has to make
changes I think I think there's one key
factor if if FX gonna be able to even
remotely dethrone steam we
it's how long is fortnight's gonna be on
top yeah you know we know apex is that
is after money yeah money thing shout
out the did he say Google he say Amazon
he said those are White Walkers he said
they made a streaming platform make sure
to compete with Netflix and no one
watches him they've already purchased
game studios - White Walkers Kintaro so
Amazon he's saying is Amazon pretty
content which I don't really think
they're doing they've been talking about
them being in the gaming space and again
made it been real super quiet about it
and just don't want to say anything so
the time is a hundred percent right but
it just doesn't seem they have that
interest like I think processes we ain't
doing that anymore we're just gonna put
twitch on anything that someone people
do do it check this out right no I mean
it's gonna be a mind-blowing right what
if this is the the bigger grant is still
get game passed some time some type of
way into woven interesting whoa I mean
like I said I was extremely surprised to
have one massive collection on Steam I
did not see that happening that is their
biggest franchise you know I'm saying
halo and then let's be real look at the
positive like not so much positive
reception right now they said in pizza
boxes non-stop they got on Twitter and
begged them to stop like PC community
tends to go in and for them just it was
such a positive thing to see the
reception in the lava
eva's are the status Bharathi got killed
off Drago
but yo I won't say this I mean does this
mean with this epic title you don't say
it all in steam and I'm playing nice
does this mean future titles does
Microsoft that ain't had your neighbor I
may be putting the money here and my
good guy Larry King King has a point
with the game pass thing cuz think about
it right Master Chief collection has
been on game passed forever at this
point how do you monetize this game on
plat like you you really have to
incentivize people to be like yeah
you're gonna pay $49.99 $59.99 again for
this or is that or is the game past
something an announcement they haven't
made yet well game passes we know is
coming and then the rumor is rumors is
that I supposed to be coming by
summertime to PC so yeah it makes sense
for that to be announced hand-in-hand
day and date again I get you can't it's
hard to justify monetizing this game
again mmm being that it's essentially
free on a service already so yeah I mean
yeah that to me that's actually coming I
keep my finger going in with this they
gave it throws references it is
interesting catch the dog sweeper
together man
things I'm definitely surprised and once
somebody's news that's coming out we got
to see how this plays out see what have
we got to see what they pulling out all
the stops talking about the how the epic
launcher is a stealing information from
steam and poking around you're confused
they weren't you afraid that's how you
know when I was talking about the
the connect watching you all that other
stuff they made people afraid of they
connect get that out of here you can see
a scooter walls yeah we'll see this is
that very interesting man Game of
Thrones man next-gen game thrown that's
what's going on people aside and making
a line since you don't ever take happily
it's crazy right there so that's all I
got pretty much we gonna wrap up low an
attic had to leave what I want to say
before he leave actually we'll get the
pole in and then we'll talk about what
are you gonna do but um yeah man so
that's it new ILP poll this week with
all the latest rumors regarding Google's
potential upcoming console announcement
at GDC how serious do you take Google as
a threat in the next-generation console
wars the choices are a not sold project
stream and Google will not win without
games be sold google's partners bank an
aggressive aggressiveness automatically
make them a threat or see i don't care
until okay google and google plus get
out of the bushes those are the choices
this is rock the aisle when it goes up
lured adequately but are we are going to
get is low situation going on and
basically he's gonna be doing a stream
right now is this rolled to huge stream
you know i'm saying we gonna hook him up
with the with the stream team he's gonna
be getting a bunch of streams and
getting a lot of your favorite youtubers
and personalities are streaming with
them so please support the brother we're
gonna put that information out there
it's gonna be coming up soon you're
gonna see the tweets from the IOP
account just get lured addict - III so
we're gonna salute that brother and get
him going on so I shot the foot his
question about which console will die
like the red wedding I love the game of
it throws right there Lord saw wait can
you find people find you what is going
on so you can probably on Twitter and
Lord style IOP and on PSN expert life
being sovereign big shout out to our
secular winner I will be getting that
code out to you later on
there tomorrow she told me what platform
you wanted for and guys look out for ILP
log net at PAX East 719 in a couple of
weeks we observe a big over there so be
sure to tune in to Lords of gaming
dotnet everything will be funneled
through Lords of gaming net will have
footage will have previews will have
interviews be there I serve one more now
keep in mind we got one more ILP before
pax and that might be special time next
week so I'm gonna get you guys the
information on that when that comes out
and well after that you know I'm saying
we would it won't be a ILP the file only
so we'll keep you up to date with what's
going on with everything cuz we will be
there in the realm of Boston doing it up
with the Lords of gaming Lord King we
can define who finds what you got going
on Lords of gaming done now with that uh
king of statues and with that uh combat
talk with the king like follow subscribe
make sure that you can see the setup so
check is that this is what I'm gonna do
right the UM this format is going to
change next week first I'm gonna give
you a hint on what's coming next week
Holy Trinity alright so everybody knows
what that means then you got a heads up
on what's coming next week it's gonna be
one video it's not gonna be split into
two videos anymore so you're going to
get a story synapses and then you're
going to get the unboxing breakdown in
one whole video we gonna be knocking be
right back - nah yeah
all day spitting bars to it yeah buddy
yeah listen man like follow subscribe
I also remember don't forget we're
looking for that uh that the gaming
reported that info news dude that DJ
academics going to Lords of gaming
dotnet like I said I'm going to put that
application in it so we can see who you
are my vote right now is for the frame
if you can't go to find you they want
you out there man I should have I seen
an application come in also I think
about young Chris was up in there
Oh Callie dues maybe I'll be on it
what's up yeah I mean we know what sir
oh yeah I hear you cake definitely
definitely so yeah shout out to
everybody supported Lords of gaming
dotnet make sure you I hit that like
subscribe or like check out the articles
out there tremendous stuff going on
you're on I'm saying and then obviously
the stream team PD was in the building
today's salute to him and the stream
team again we're gonna be working with
Lord at it let's get attic to e3 stream
is gonna be poppin we got some huge
surprise some big name there's gonna be
working with him to get that raise some
little cash up for the brother he's
going through it right now so we got
that and then obviously I can said on
Lords of gaming all the tremendous
articles man oh the team that we got
currently is killing it we just want to
add more just greedy that's that but um
yeah - all I got your ego - audio is
gonna be up order which cause Spotify
Google Play I I Tunes all that good
stuff you already seen that come back
talk cleaning statues coming with the
new joint
no last word this Ricky born artist
ochita is traveling when will come back
next week we gonna have some special
guests - we gonna start getting guests
when the last word so please check that
out
you know I'm saying but that's all I got
you know I'm say Forte already know you
know slobo you already know just ready
you're a CEO you're gonna say we're
gonna do it up with yo everybody enjoy
your son if anybody else got anything
else we are out phase